ich spreche hier weil ich alles dafür
tun um einen erneuten landesweiten
shutdown zu verhindern
geben wir alle als bürgerinnen und
bürger dieser gesellschaft wieder mehr
aufeinander
denn alle regeln verordnungen alle
maßnahmen nützen wenig bis nichts wenn
sie nicht von den menschen angenommen
und eingehalten werden ich sage das hier
weil ich unbedingt unternehmen und
arbeitsplätze schützen will weil ich
kinder und jugendliche in den kitas und
in den schulen sehen will
wir haben gesehen wie belastend die
einschränkungen sind wie sie die sozial
schwächsten besonders treffen wie sie
bestehende ungleichheiten noch einmal
vertiefen
wir wollen dass die wirtschaft sich
erholt wir wollen dass die künstlerinnen
und künstler wieder auftreten und
spielen können
wir wollen dass kinder und enkel ihre
eltern und großeltern sehen können also
die alle wollen verhindern dass es zu
einem zweiten landesweiten schatten
wir erleben zurzeit wie die vorsicht
nachlässt wie sich alle wieder nach nähe
sehen nach berührungen nach
gemeinsamkeit nachfeiern im familien und
freundeskreis oder an öffentlichen orten
einfach nach unbeschwert hätte das spüre
ich selbst und natürlich wollen das ganz
besonders die jungen leute in unserem
land aber wir riskieren gerade alles was
wir in den letzten monaten erreicht
haben wir dürfen es nicht dazu kommen
lassen das wieder landesweite
einschränkungen wieder hohe ökonomische
und emotionale verluste drohen
dass ein sterbender mensch im
krankenhaus oder im pflegeheim
mutterseelenallein sterben muss bei
seinen liebsten
wir brauchen immer noch abstand als
ausdruck von für sorgen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren